here is a video of Robert F Kennedy Jr
who unfortunately will not be on a
debate stage with Joe Biden because
obviously the Democrats are not going to
allow that to happen here he is talking
about how the CIA part of the machine
uses their propaganda machine against us
the people of the United States of
America
there's a provision of the CIA Charter
that says that the CIA cannot propaganda
I see American people President Obama
adopted in 2016.
that essentially reopened the door for
operation Mockingbird so that the CIA
began once again to to propaganda is
American how are they doing that high
level intelligence officials are or
people associated with the intelligent
industry
are running those journals like Noah
schlachmann who runs on a linkstone who
came from Daily Beast Daily Beast was
run by John Avalon who was you know who
has deep ties to the intelligence
agencies but even journals like
Smithsonian and Smithsonian and National
Geographic
nature
um The Washington Post the New York
Times appeared to be uh compromised by
the CIA we know from
I'm the
um Twitter files
that's both the FBI and CIA
we're operating portals within the uh
Twitter and Facebook
that allowed them to manipulate
information and to do a deep platform
people and to you know silence certain
people that they didn't like in those in
the social media operation Mockingbird
was a an operation to compromise
American journalists there were some 400
editors journalists
um from you know all the largest
Publications the New York Times have
been compromised
um The Washington Post what do you mean
by compromise for people who are they
were functioning the high level people
with those
at those journals were actually were
working for the agency or had you know
assigned uh secrecy agreements with the
CIA and at the CBS ABC NBC after 75 when
it all came out during the church
committee hearings
the CIA promised that it would no longer
compromise Americans it continued the
program to compromise journalists all
over the world and today the CIA is the
biggest funder of Journalism in the
world how about presentation through USA
ID
and that little Twilight Zone before you
fall asleep every night I'm thinking
about what I'm gonna do in the first
weeks when I get into office about
fixing these agencies
um one at a time you know that's
something I'm excited about
and that is unbelievably powerful stuff
and it's kind of like oh let's look
behind the curtain I don't want to see
that better put the curtain back because
you don't want to think that your
government in essence the the
three-letter agencies have been
weaponized against you but interestingly
and we'll follow up with this tomorrow
in Phoenix maybe you can give me
something on the Fly he mentions this
guy Noah shackman I think his name is
who I think now works for Rolling Stone
used to be the editor-in-chief of Daily
Beast he used to write hit pieces about
me all the time and about the
intellectual dark web he called me all
right I got into a big fight with him so
now really think about this for a second
this guy who RFK Jr is saying is
basically working for the CIA who runs
at one point was running Daily Beast
running uh running Rolling Stone Etc uh
he was running around calling a whole
bunch of people Jordan Peterson Ben
Shapiro et cetera et cetera I don't mean
to make this about me but you see it
right like you can see the thing that
they have the prison that they have that
they have put in front of everyone's
faces so everyone cannot get an honest
estimation of what is true anymore it is
absolutely insane